Define your terms.
Well, it's not a democracy in that people
cannot vote for their leaders.
It's not a dictatorship.
Maybe that conjures up images of Hitler or Mussolini.
It's not really that either.
You have a strong leader
at the top of a Communist Party or a one party state.
And this leader, Xi Jinping,
he doesn't have absolute power,
but he has a lot of power.
It's a one party state.
That may be the best way to think of it,
where there's one political party
that runs all facets of life, from companies
to universities to the government.
The term democracy is really important
in Chinese politics
because it goes back
to the beginning of modern China in 1919.
There is this thing called the May 4th Movement,
and people asked for Mr.
Democracy and Mr. Science.
So they wanted China
not to be run by emperors and things like that.
But democracy means a lot of different things
to different people.
But the Communist Party claims that it's an heir
to this movement and they want to cloak themselves
in the mantle of this enlightened movement.
So they got to say that they are a democracy,
even though they are not really a democracy
based on most definitions.
The short answer is not really.
You do have freedom of speech
based on the Chinese constitution, but the scope
for expressing opinion has decreased
quite a lot in recent years.
So, you know,
it used to be that you could debate
a lot of different social policies.
The best way to deal with
China's rural problems,
the best kind of economic policies
that was seen as
an open field for for a robust discussion
on all kinds of different things.
That's become a lot less in recent years, so that now
the area where you can express opinions is
really narrow.
The Communist Party
had this disaster period that when it ran China,
that kind of ended in the late 1970s
and that included the world's worst recorded famine
and a period of turmoil
known as the Cultural Revolution.
And China
was a really poor country,
and the Communist Party had lost people's support.
So they decided to try to win it back by ruling China
with more pragmatic policies with a lighter touch.
They began to allow economic reforms,
which has created
the prosperous superpower that we know,
but they also permitted more expression of opinions
and religious participation and things like that.
There were always clear limits,
and we can see that
in 1989, with the Tiananmen Square protests
that resulted in a massacre of hundreds of people
because people were challenging the party.
The party responded
with just brute force
by sending in the army and clearing the square.
So that was always clear.
But overall, there was still this scope
for debate and discussion in the 1990 and 2000.
And I think what happened was about 15 years ago,
the party decided that things had gone too far
and they needed to rein it in.
And so they started after the 2008 Beijing
Olympics to crack down much more seriously on dissent.
People understand that the political system
is run by the party and that they may be party members
and they're they may therefore
think they have a bit more influence.
But most people,
let's face
it, are not party members
is 1.4 billion people in China.
There are about 90 million party members.
That's a lot of people.
But that's still sort of like one in 15
people are in the party.
And even if you're in the party,
I don't think you're going to really feel
like you have a say
because you can't vote on Xi Jinping
even if you're in the Communist Party.
So there's nothing it's not like in a system
that has, say,
you're a member of the Republican Party
or the Democratic Party
and you can vote in a primary
for who your candidate should be.
There's nothing like that in China.
So I'd say basically people don't feel like
they have a say.
The party is fairly
tolerant toward people
who have constructive criticism.
So if you've got a concrete problem,
like let's say you're in a factory,
your factory hasn't paid you
for two weeks or two months or something like that,
and you protest
even if you protested,
if the party
the party would look at that and say, Aha,
those people have not been paid,
we're going to pay them.
We've got a big slush fund here to take care of this.
We're going to just pay everybody.
As long as you
then go home,
they're going to be okay with what you did.
So the party isn't against any sort of feedback.
It's not like you have to completely
keep your mouth closed.
So I think in that sense,
people may feel that
they have some input in their lives,
but there's no real direct way to to
choose your leaders.
So some of
that they don't necessarily want democracy,
but they probably think of democracy as meaning
the party listens to people and people
have some sort of feedback into the party.
So if people feel that they aren't being listened to
and this is the case
with the COVID lockdowns,
then they feel that that's not democratic,
that's not democracy.
So think of democracy
maybe is more participatory as more of an interaction
or a dialog
rather than I go to a ballot box
and vote for somebody.
And I guess I guess is sort of the answer.
They want to feel that
they have some stable life, that they have.
Tomorrow will be a better day that, you know,
they'll be more prosperous,
that their children can go to school
and so on and so forth,
just like people in every country.
And they want a political system
that can make that possible.
And by and large, China's political system,
despite its often brutal
methods of governing, has delivered
those kind of goods over the past 30 or 40 years.
The question, I think, going
forward is
if it can't deliver that, then what happens?